- Irish is a different language?
(bouncy music)
- [Voiceover] Tigh.
- Whaaaat?
- Who could forget a tadgch?
- Taig.
- Tad-g-h?
- Tag.
- Tod.
- Tig?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, like
the first syllable of tiger.
- Ohhhhhhh.
- I didn't see that coming.
- [Voiceover] Rosheen.
- Uh-oh. We got one of those weird symbols
that I never knew what to do with.
- In a way that you
wouldn't expect, raisin.
- Reesewin.
- Roisin.
- Rozeen.
- Rizin.
- [Voiceover] It's Rosheen.
(snorts)
- Rosheeeeen. So what does that symbol do?
- [Voiceover] Sersha.
- This one I should know because
there's an actress that has this name,
and she was in a Wes Anderson movie.
- These combination of
letters is just so strange.
- Shar-say.
- Sarosee.
- Swearzee.
- Sweersha?
- Sersha? These are really pretty names,
but I, they're spelled so weird.
- [Voiceover] Kiva.
- Guys, you tell me what
you do with an m and an h,
cause I'm at a loss.
- This looks like Portuguese.
- Cha-mee.
- Comehee.
- Maybe it's just simple,
maybe it's just Cowmee.
- Come-hee?
- Kiva? I'm sorry, what?
There's a v in there?
- [Voiceover] Owen.
- Some of these letters
are not being used.
It's just me figuring out which ones.
- Egan. Totally Egan.
- Uh, Johan.
- Eogan.
- Ethan.
- Eugan.
- I give up.
- [Voiceover] Owen.
- Owen? No.
- Why is a e in there
if it has no purpose?
If there's no e in
Owen, oh, yeah there is.
Never mind.
- [Voiceover] Maraid.
- I don't know what the
little thing is above the e.
- [Voiceover] It's called a fada.
- Maired.
- Maeread.
- So I think it would be Mairead, but
it's probably like Vaired.
- Merd.
- Mary.
- Maraid?
What is that, it's like a,
it's like a male parade.
- I don't even know what a's are anymore.
- [Voiceover] Neiff.
- This name is just Name.
- Naame. Niama?
- Niam-hee. Naomi!
- Neeam.
- Like Liam, but it's an n?
- Niam.
- Nimh. Like, uh, the mice.
- Nieff? I'm sorry, what?
I am not getting that from this.
- [Voiceover] Granya.
- This is a term of endearment
for your grandmother.
- Granny.
- I don't know how else to pronounce it
other than Grainy.
- Gra-Graenee.
- Gra-Grainee.
- There's literally no
other way to say this.
And if they say it a
different way, it's wrong.
It's Grain.
- What is it?
- [Voiceover] Granya.
- Granya.
- That's beautiful.
- I feel like they can make a big comeback
in like a hipster way.
Which, the Irish better watch out.
- [Voiceover] That's not to say
that Irish names are confusing.
I just find language confusing.
- I can barely speak English.